[Music]
thank you I'm just gonna class the water
please I have to save all my money cuz
I'm here to find my sister
she's been taken taken like like by man
who sell hot white virgins to conchiglie
n' airs on yours i am very moved by your
story or there anything you like I'll
have a club sandwich and an order fries
two slices a cake do you want any cake
no three slices of cake and a diet coke
impressive I'm a con artist sisters in
arms I had no idea how small time I was
until I met you candy why are women
better suited to calm the men cuz we're
used to faking it because no man will
ever believe a woman is smarter than he
is is it valuable $500,000 I like it cuz
it's shiny
I could be the potting living you needed
teach me your sugar baby ways take this
to the guest room Butler person first
listen there's nothing more compelling
to a man than a vulnerable woman observe
wow you just tear up like that can you
make the tea roll down your cheek oh oh
no you try gee are you constipated if
you want to be like me you must be
trained for any situation she's ready
he's the mark he's a tech millionaire
billionaire out there try to be as
inconspicuous as possible
yeah if this person would just scoot
over
would you mind sir sir
[Music]
men always underestimate us and that is
what we use
[Music]
you let her get away huh she dresses
again save us means says it suits her
bird Dallas is a terrible shot that
wasn't expected
[Music]